foreign
artificial intelligence is known as the
hottest job of the century because it
can lead to financial gain and a
plethora of opportunities however AI is
not limited to just one area it has
spread its roots into almost every feed
making it an integral part of our daily
lives we rely on AI for things like
Gmail reply prompts Amazon purchase
recommendations Spotify music
suggestions anyone schedule appointment
AI analyzes various behavioral aspects
such as past playlists browsing history
and previous orders to create accurate
behavioral models to give you a perfect
recommendation that pops up right on
your screen at the moment AI engineering
is one of the most lucrative career
paths in the world at present the AI job
market has been growing phenomenally the
entry level annual average air engineer
salary in India is around 15 lakhs per
annum which is significantly higher than
the average salary of any other
Engineering Graduate the AI engineer
salary can be as high as 50 lakhs at
high end positions according to
Glassdoor the average salary in the
United States is over 120 000 and can go
as high as three hundred thousand
dollars however you must note that these
figures can vary significantly based on
several factors the first factor is the
type of AI engineering that is machine
learning data science Etc second is
experience and skills and qualifications
the top most companies hiring artificial
intelligence Engineers right now are IBM
Google JP Morgan Intel Oracle Microsoft
and Etc currently artificial
intelligence is one of the most popular
and actively pursued topics worldwide
with virtually every business attempting
to integrate and adapt AI in the
operations to Greater extent to advance
your career in artificial intelligence
we invite you to register for simply
lens professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM which will equip
you with the necessary skills to excel
in this field well if you are unaware of
what AI means then nothing to worry
about it is not rocket science let's
dive deep into AI what is artificial
intelligence and why should we learn
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence refers to Field of computer
science that focuses on creating
intelligent machines that can perform
tasks like humans these machines are
designed to support decision making
processes by analyzing vast amounts of
data much like how human synthesize
information to make informed decisions
learning artificial intelligence machine
learning and deep learning can be
incredibly valuable as these
Technologies enhance current processes
and provide new opportunities for
advancement AI can provide you with
valuable skills and knowledge that can
be applied to various domains contribute
to Innovation and open up new career
opportunities so here are the 5 reasons
why you should learn AI the first is the
skill of the century artificial
intelligence is not just a buzzword for
the year or decade but for the century
while it is true that AI is posed to
replace many human jobs it is also
creating all 130 million new roles
across various Industries to stay
relevant and competitive in this
transformational era being part of the
AI Revolution is crucial from Fashion to
finance is one of the fastest growing
Technologies making its Mark in every
sector
accounting for an average of 18 percent
jobs in most companies second is AI is
everywhere even in small and
medium-sized Enterprises smes customized
websites with unique user experiences
are becoming increasingly essential and
chat boards are fulfilling customers
information needs without them having to
visit physical stores chat boards are
automated computer programs that
interact with website visitors as if
they were human and they are cost
effective and available 24 7 worldwide
their responses are based on the
information fed to them and the content
available on the website if you keep up
with technology news you have likely
heard of self-driving cars while it may
be scary to imagine traveling without a
human driver the automobile industry has
already designed such cars and is
testing them out self-driving cars will
hit the road sooner than we expect smart
home devices also change how we live by
adjusting the environment based on our
preferences using machine learning and
ai ai is transforming several Industries
such as the automotive industry music
recommendations smart home devices
online customer support security
surveillance retail and Healthcare as
the saying goes AI is everywhere the
next reason is data data and more data
humans generate incredible data daily
totaling over 2.5 quintillion bytes this
data is collected from various sources
including a visual and communication
inputs and is then fed into machine
learning algorithms to reveal patterns
of behavior and consumer insights
companies are racing to adopt AI
Technologies to use these insights to
drive sales and gain a Competitive Edge
the next reason is Big Bright career a
career in artificial intelligence can
provide a high salary and a wide range
of opportunities AI professionals can
pursue careers in fields such as machine
learning engineering software
engineering Hardware engineering
research engineering business
intelligence development and data
science companies such as Google Amazon
Nokia and Microsoft are among those that
actively seek out AI candidates salaries
for AI professionals range from one
hundred thousand dollars to 150 000 in
the United States and 15 lakhs in India
and the last one is AI is versatile
artificial intelligence is an incredibly
versatile field with a wide range of
applications while many people associate
AI with computer and space related
Industries it also plays a significant
role in areas such as banking Healthcare
security mobile flow detection clothing
and much more for example virtual Health
assistance VSA that can help patients
manage their medication recommend
preventative health screenings such as
treatments and even provide personalized
tight recommendations based on a
patient's health history and medications
the list of reasons to learn artificial
intelligence is vast as are the
opportunities it presents the growth of
artificial intelligence is ongoing and
it continued to offer competitive
benefits across all sectors of business
don't hesitate any longer take advantage
of the benefits that artificial
intelligence can offer if you are keen
on
we recommend checking out our artificial
intelligence certification training
course now the question is are you ready
to build a successful career in
artificial intelligence comment down
your answers and don't forget to check
the course link from the description box
below till then stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign